.
* Miauen *
Schon als Kind träumten sie davon,
mal Tierärztin zu werden:
Florence, Alix und Éléonore
stiegen mit viel Leidenschaft
ins Berufsleben ein.
Aber schon bald merkten sie,
dass es im Alltag einer Tierärztin
viel Schwieriges
und Unvorhergesehenes gibt ...
* Kreischen *
... aber auch viel Freude.
Hier sind sie:
die neuen Tierärztinnen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Geheimnisvolle Westernmusik *
Florences Tag beginnt
im freiburgischen Wilden Westen.
Dort erwartet sie
ein besonderes Tier.
Sébastien ist
ein leidenschaftlicher Westernreiter
und hat vor drei Wochen
im Internet ein Zebu gekauft.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Sébastien) Opa. Hoppla-ho.
- Hoppla.
Hoppla. Ui.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Sie faszinieren mich schon lange.
Am Morgen meines Geburtstags
sah ich auf Facebook,
dass jemand ein Zebu verkauft
und ich dachte: "Jetzt oder nie."
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich habe noch nie ein Zebu gesehen,
nur im Internet. Ich googelte es.
Ja, genau, sie sind wild.
Uh-hu-hu.
* Westernmusik *
Es ist eigentlich
nicht besonders gross,
aber es verhält sich eher
wie ein Wildtier
und ist nicht wirklich zutraulich.
Es ist impulsiv.
Wenn es die Leute oder die Umgebung
nicht kennt, ist es gestresst.
Aber es ist sehr anhänglich.
- Ja, es ist süss.
Derjenige, der es mir verkaufte,
hat mich gewarnt.
Er sagte,
es sei nervös und unberechenbar.
Aber genau diese Herausforderung
reizt mich an ungewöhnlichen Tieren.
Voilà. Gut, ganz ruhig.
Wir merkten sofort,
dass ein Zebu rasch überfordert ist
und auch gefährlich werden kann.
Man merkt es sofort,
weil es auf einen losgehen will.
Ja.
- Das merkt man rasch.
Bei Leuten,
die es nicht kennt, ist es extrem.
Wenn Kinder am Zaun vorbeigehen,
rennt es los.- Wirklich? Wow.
Das Lasso ...
(Lachend)
Wirklich wie in einem Film.
Wenn gar nichts mehr geht,
nimmt Sébastien das Lasso.
* Lachen *
Das ist schwierig.
* Schnelle Westernmusik *
* Lachen *
Es klappt nicht immer.
* Schnelle Westernmusik *
Wenn ein Tier stehen bleibt,
geht es,
aber wenn sich ein Tier bewegt,
wird es kompliziert.
Ich finde es ziemlich cool.
Wo werden Zebus
eigentlich gezüchtet?
Im Wallis.
Okay. Ah!
Ein Horn hat er erwischt.
Endlich ist Raja ruhiggestellt.
Bringst du mir das Halfter?
- Ja.
Élodie, Sébastiens Freundin,
kommt nur so nahe wie nötig.
Kannst du es öffnen
und ihr gleich überziehen?
Ich halte sie fest.
Schon beim Kauf wunderte sich
Sébastien über den dicken Bauch.
Daher sollte Florence nun
herausfinden, ob Raja trächtig ist.
(Beruhigend) Ja.
- Die Arme.
Sie ist total lieb, aber wenn sie
jemanden nicht kennt, hat sie Panik.
Wenn ich mit ihr allein bin,
ist sie zutraulich.
Mich greift sie nicht mehr an.
- Im Gegensatz zu anfangs.
Ja, genau. Am ersten Tag
drückte sie alle an die Wand.
Ach ja?
- Man muss schon aufpassen.
Ein Zebu ist ziemlich unberechenbar.
Wenn es jemanden nicht kennt,
verteidigt es sich.
D.h., es greift die Leute an oder
schlägt mit den Hinterbeinen aus.
Man muss sich also
vorn und hinten absichern.
Also ...
Normalerweise macht Florence
solche Untersuchungen bei Kühen.
Diese sind allerdings
viel friedlicher.
Komm. Komm, komm, komm.
Das geht schon. Komm.
- Sie ist nervös.
Ho-ho-ho.
Okay?
- Ja.
* Ruhige Westernmusik *
(Beruhigend) So, meine Schöne.
Es reichte nicht, um es zu spüren.
Ja, wir warten,
bis sie sich beruhigt hat.
Plötzlich sprang es auf.
Man weiss manchmal nicht, wieso.
Ich musste den Arm rausziehen,
um zu verhindern,
dass er mir im Zebu gebrochen wird.
Gut.
* Sébastien tätschelt Raja. *
Tja, wenn sie so gestresst ist ...
- Jetzt hält sie still.
Oh, hier drin
ist es ganz anders als üblich.
* Lachen *
Wow.
Da sie zur Familie der Kuh gehören,
dachte ich mir schon, dass Zebus
eine ähnliche Anatomie haben.
Aber jede Art ist anders
und hinzu kommt,
dass es schwierig ist,
sich zu konzentrieren,
wenn die Hand drin ist, weil man
nicht vom Zebu getreten werden will.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Oh. Ja. Schön.
Ist sie trächtig?
- Ja.
Bei einer Kuh würde ich sagen,
im fünften oder sechsten Monat,
aber hier ...
Mit einem sechs Monate alten Kalb
im Bauch
darf Raja
schon ein bisschen rund sein.
Wenn das Kleine männlich ist,
wird Fleisch daraus.
Ansonsten wird es aufgezogen
und wir vergrössern den Bestand.
Ho-ho-ho.
Alles klar?
- Ja, ja.
Ich bin es mir gewohnt.
Ich warte,
bis sie sich beruhigt hat.
Geh doch schon mal raus.
- Ja, ich gehe raus.
Raja ist halt doch ein Wildtier
und einen Tierarzt
hat sie sicher noch nie gesehen.
Gehst du nicht auf mich los?
Bist du genervt?
Ja, ja, alles in Ordnung.
Komm, geh zu deinem Freund.
Ja.
Ich finde es ein cooles Tier.
Ich mag es.
Ja, sie sind wunderschön.
- Ich mag Tiere mit Hörnern.
Das sind gute Nachrichten.
- Gut.
Es hat gut geklappt.
Ich stellte es mir schlimmer vor.
Perfekt.
- Uff.
Florence
kommt in vier Monaten wieder,
wenn das junge Zebu da ist.
* Ruhige Westernmusik *
Im Tierspital in Bern
hat Alix Morgenschicht.
Beide sind symmetrisch.
- Ja.
Hallo.
Ich komme morgens recht früh,
eine halbe bis eine Stunde früher.
Auch abends
wird es meistens ziemlich spät.
Das magst du, was?
Ja, ja, ja. Hallo, du.
Zuerst kümmere ich mich eine
halbe Stunde um meine Patient:innen.
Ich schaue, wie es ihnen geht und ob
etwas Neues in den Unterlagen steht.
Dieser direkte Kontakt
ist mir sehr wichtig.
Wir Ärzt:innen sind auch
als Menschen hier anwesend.
Wir haben Gefühle gegenüber den
Tieren und sie gegenüber uns auch.
Und schon kommt der erste Patient
in die Notfallstation.
Das eingelieferte Kätzchen
war zweieinhalb Monate alt.
Es hatte ein Kiefertrauma
und kam ohne Voranmeldung zu uns.
Wir untersuchten es und stellten
einen offenen Kieferbruch fest.
So hätte es
nicht weiterleben können.
Einen doppelten Kieferbruch
muss man sofort operieren.
Eine Studentin
sprach mit dem Halter des Kätzchens,
aber dieser sieht es leider anders.
Als ich ihm die Kosten der Operation
mitteilte, war es ihm doch zu teuer.
Daher entschied er,
das Tier einschläfern zu lassen.
Das fand ich persönlich
extrem schade,
weil das Kätzchen, das wir hätten
einschläfern sollen, so jung war.
Aber ich kenne mich mit den Regeln
noch nicht so gut aus.
Alix kann es nicht glauben.
Jeder hat andere Ansichten, aber für
mich wäre das keine Option gewesen.
Eine so junge Katze
mit Chancen auf Heilung zu töten -
ein wirklich schwieriger Moment.
Alix will das Kätzchen retten
und hat eine Idee:
Man könnte dem Halter sagen,
er solle auf seine Katze verzichten.
Wir hoffen das Beste.
Aber wer bezahlt dann die Operation?
Man braucht Leute, die ihre Zeit
gratis zur Verfügung stellen,
und v.a.
braucht man einen guten Chirurgen.
Sorry, nur ganz kurz,
eine Sekunde, bitte.
Ja, klar.
- Schau dir diese Fraktur an.
Die Besitzer wollten die Katze
einschläfern lassen.
Aber wir würden sie gern
bei uns behalten.- Ja.
Wir wissen nicht,
wann wir sie operieren können.
Zeig mal.
- Sie ist zweieinhalb Monate alt.
Oh! Wisst ihr schon,
wie es passiert ist?
Nein, wir wissen es nicht.
- Mhm.
Er ist stabil
und bewegt sich normal.
Ansonsten ist alles okay.
Ueli operiert zwar gerade, aber der
Pfleger geht trotzdem kurz zu ihm.
(Chirurg) Ist sie schon hier?
- Ja, sie ist hier.
War es ein Autounfall?
- (Stefania) Nein, im Haus.
Okay.
Hier hast du es wieder.
Ah, super.
- Ja.
Zum Glück hat Alix das getan.
Der Besitzer muss nur noch die
Verzichtserklärung unterschreiben.
Und bereits der nächste Notfall.
Raphaël kam mit seinem Kater Arès
aus dem Val-de-Ruz hierher.
Er hat seine Katze vor elf Jahren
beim Tierschutzverein adoptiert,
aber seit ein paar Tagen
stimmt etwas nicht mit ihr.
Sie entdeckten die Probleme,
als Arès urinierte?
Genau, am Donnerstag.
Als ich von der Arbeit
nach Hause kam,
sah ich eine Pfütze Urin
auf dem Boden, was mich beunruhigte.
Ich wunderte mich,
putzte es jedoch einfach auf.
Am nächsten Tag geschah es wieder.
Am Sonntag war ich zu Hause und sah,
dass er heftig zuckte.
Es sah sehr schmerzhaft aus.
Er zuckte am ganzen Körper
und speichelte.
Fiel er zur Seite?
- Ja, er fiel zur Seite.
Arès hatte zu Hause
einen Krampfanfall.
Der Halter sah seinen Kater
zur Seite fallen.
Er machte Bewegungen,
die man als "pedalen" bezeichnet,
ein Strampeln, als würde er rennen,
und er bewegte die Pfoten im Kreis.
Zudem war er ohnmächtig.
Er reagierte nicht auf Ansprache
und ihm lief Speichel aus dem Maul.
Manche Katzen verlieren Urin oder
ihr Darm entleert sich auch noch.
Da sich die Anfälle häufen,
befürchtet Alix
einen schweren Gehirnschaden -
wahrscheinlich ein Gehirntumor.
Von Krebs zu hören,
ist natürlich schon beängstigend.
Ich dachte: "Oh Gott, man muss
die Katze wohl einschläfern."
Es ist Gehirnkrebs.
Alix möchte herausfinden,
was in Arès' Gehirn genau abläuft.
Raphaël lebt allein
mit seinen zwei Katzen.
Die Vorstellung,
Arès nach elf Jahren zu verlieren,
bereitet ihm grosse Probleme.
Mag er Tierärzte?
- Er ist grundsätzlich zutraulich.
Super. Ich nehme ihn mit
und bringe ihn später wieder.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Super, bis später.
Die beiden Katzen
sind mir sehr wichtig.
Ich habe Glück: Sie sind verschmust
und sehr zutraulich.
Oh, so eine schwere Katze.
Sie sind mir sehr nahe und wir
haben eine enge Bindung entwickelt -
ich zu ihnen und sie zu mir.
Arès schmust bereits mit Alix -
und auch sie
ist ganz von ihm eingenommen.
Ja, du bist ein Braver, ein
ganz Braver. Du machst das so gut.
Als Arès zu uns kam,
war er ziemlich stabil.
Er reagierte normal und
war uns gegenüber sehr zutraulich.
Aber wir sind trotzdem beunruhigt,
weil wir wissen, dass er
bereits mehrere Anfälle hatte.
Arès kann jeden Moment
wieder einen Anfall haben.
Daher will Alix möglichst rasch
ein MRI organisieren.
Arès wird sediert,
damit er sich ja nicht bewegt.
Mit diesem Apparat
können die Radiolog:innen
das Gehirn der Katze
dreidimensional untersuchen.
Und tatsächlich ist auf dem Bild-
schirm ein kleiner Fleck zu sehen,
der den Ärzt:innen gar nicht gefällt.
Oh!
Das sieht gar nicht gut aus.
Siehst du das im Hirn?- Nein.
Ein Tumor.
- Wirklich?
Im MRI sahen wir, dass tatsächlich
ein kleiner Tumor vorhanden ist.
Er ist zwar nur klein,
aber er kann natürlich für
Arès' Anfälle verantwortlich sein.
Ich rufe wegen Arès' MRI an.
Die Neurologin schlägt Raphaël vor,
den Tumor herausoperieren zu lassen.
Wären Sie theoretisch bereit dazu,
diese Operation vornehmen zu lassen?
Wie denken Sie darüber?
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist gar keine Frage.
Meine Katze
lebt seit elf Jahren bei mir
und ich zögere keinen Augenblick.
Es kommen ungefähr 1'000 Fr. hinzu.
Sie sagte,
er habe gute Überlebenschancen.
Darum will ich das machen lassen.
Der Preis spielt keine Rolle.
Auf Wiederhören.
Eine so heikle Operation
in diesem kleinen Katzenhirn
muss gut vorbereitet werden.
Die Operation ist v.a.
in unseren Köpfen eine grosse Sache,
weil es darum geht,
am Gehirn zu operieren.
Das ist auch für die Besitzer
oftmals so.
Auch für uns ist es etwas
Besonderes, nichts Alltägliches.
Man muss immer
auf Komplikationen vorbereitet sein.
Daher ist es oft auch in Bezug auf
die Anästhesie eine grössere Sache.
Arès kommt auf die Intensivstation,
wo Alix bereits dafür sorgte,
dass ihm nichts fehlt.
Ja ...
* Schnurren *
Es wird alles gut, keine Angst.
Da er nicht bei seinem Herrchen
sein kann, sucht Arès Trost bei Alix.
* Schnurren *
* Alix macht beruhigende Laute. *
(Beruhigend) Ja.
Der Kater wartet geduldig
auf seine Operation.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Jeden Freitag fährt Éléonore
zum Freiburger Tierschutzverein.
In diesem Heim werden jährlich
bis zu 1'000 Tiere aufgenommen.
Und Tag für Tag
setzen sich die zwölf Angestellten
und die freiwilligen Helfer:innen
dafür ein,
dass die Tiere
wieder ein neues Zuhause finden.
In 4 Std. muss Éléonore möglichst
viele dieser Tiere behandeln können.
Alexandre
ist für die Hunde zuständig.
Seine Eltern züchten selbst Hunde.
Daher kennt er die Vierbeiner
von klein auf.
Heute zeigt er Éléonore
die Neuankömmlinge dieser Woche.
Salut, mein Lieber.
Riecht es nach Schaf?
Oh! Riecht es nach Schaf?
Danke.
* Lachen *
Dieser junge Pinscher heisst Bobby.
Ich schaue mir kurz
das Impfbüchlein an.
Bei ihm mache ich
alle Impfungen neu, nicht wahr?
Das ist mühsam, was?
- Ja, wenn nicht geimpft wurde ...
Ja, hallo.
Dieser Hund gehörte einem Paar
und die Halterinnen trennten sich.
Leider gaben sie ihn danach weg,
weil der Hund eine Art Symbol
für die Beziehung war
und es zu sehr wehgetan hätte,
ihn anzusehen.
Bobby hat also alles verloren
und ist jetzt im Tierheim.
Bist du sympa, Bobby?
Der arme Hund.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen:
Er ist zu Hause
und plötzlich ist er hier -
bei Leuten, die er nicht kennt,
und Hunden, die er nicht kennt.
Es ist traurig, das zu sehen.
Es ist nur ein Tier,
das geliebt werden will.
Die Mitarbeiter:innen
gehen jeden Abend nach Hause
und die Tiere bleiben hier.
Hier geht es ihnen gut.
Sie werden umsorgt und haben
genügend Futter, aber keine Familie.
Machen wir zuerst das
und dann die Krallen?
Bist du einverstanden?
Genau.
Du bist eine kleine Spitzmaus.
Ja, genau wie eine Spitzmaus.
* Lachen *
So, voilà.
Oh, komm.
Bei der zweiten Impfung
bekam er eine Panikattacke.
* Bobby kreischt und jault panisch. *
Hey, hey, hey.
* Panisches Schreien *
Mit viel Geduld kann Alexandre den
kleinen Pinscher wieder beruhigen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass das Tier traumatisiert wurde.
Damit müssen wir umgehen.
Es liegt an uns, uns ihnen
anzupassen, nicht umgekehrt.
* Bobby kreischt. *
Oh!
Ich habe nichts getan.
- Nehmen wir den Maulkorb?
* Kreischen *
He, he.
Alexandre
muss zu härteren Mitteln greifen:
ein Maulkorb und ein Handtuch,
um Bobby besser halten zu können.
Er will ja nur das Beste
für das Hündchen.
Diese hier habe ich
noch nicht geschnitten.
* Alexandre und Éléonore
machen beruhigende Laute. *
Diese muss ich noch stärker kürzen,
sonst wächst sie ein.
Voilà.
Jetzt noch die zweite Impfung,
die Éléonore vorhin
nicht mehr vornehmen konnte.
Fertig.
- He, he, he, he, he.
Alles okay?
- Fertig.- Alles okay.
Bobby ist wieder zufrieden.
In ein paar Wochen wird er
bei einer neuen Familie unterkommen.
Salut, mein Lieber.
Auch Teko bekommt heute
seine jährliche Impfung.
Komm.
So, Jahreskontrolle für den Herrn,
was? Man sieht sich nicht so oft.
Er ist neun
und schon zu alt und zu gross,
um von einer Familie
aufgenommen zu werden.
Es ist immer etwas traurig,
die jährliche Impfung
im Tierheim zu machen,
weil das heisst, dass das Tier
wieder ein Jahr hier war
und nicht von einer Familie
adoptiert wurde.
Teko ist zu alt. Rein statistisch
gesehen wird er kein Zuhause finden.
Das macht mich schon traurig.
Komm.
Ja, du Lieber, Lieber, Lieber.
Er ist halt gross und alt.
Familien wollen lieber
kein altes Tier übernehmen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Das tut mir sehr leid
für diese Tiere.
Die meisten von ihnen
sind liebe Tiere.
Du bist gut und lieb, was?
Sie sind neuen Menschen gegenüber
kein bisschen aggressiv.
Ihnen fehlt nur eins: ein Zuhause.
Es ist hart - auch für diejenigen,
die im Tierheim arbeiten -,
abends nach Hause zu gehen und
die Tiere allein im Heim zu lassen.
* Bellen *
So, kommst du mit mir?
Éléonore nimmt ein Nagetier,
das operiert werden muss,
mit in die Praxis.
Alexandre kümmert sich
um seine Heiminsassen
und schenkt ihnen
Aufmunterung und Zuneigung.
Fünf davon hat er bereits adoptiert.
Wenn man hier arbeitet,
gibt es immer wieder ein Tier,
das dein Herz berührt.
Ein spontanes Verlieben,
ein Spezialfall,
den man nirgends platzieren kann.
Dann kommt er halt mit nach Hause,
wo er sich wohlfühlt.
Nun haben wir fünf davon.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Für mich sollte es keine Hunde
geben, die im Tierheim sterben.
Darum nehme ich die alten Hunde mit,
weil ich nicht möchte,
dass sie dort
ihre letzten Tage verbringen.
Ich könnte es nicht
mit mir vereinbaren,
wenn sie in diesem Moment
allein wären.
* Sanfte Klänge *
In vielen Berufen
kann man abschalten,
wenn man abends nach Hause kommt.
Wenn man mit Tieren arbeitet,
ist das fast unmöglich.
Man denkt die ganze Zeit an sie.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Im Tierspital Bern ist Hochbetrieb.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Drollige Musik *
Guten Tag. Barbarino,
Tierärztin der Notfallstation.
Ist das Serenity?
- Ja, genau.
Alix kümmert sich
um die Neueintritte.
In dieser Zeit wird Arès
in den Operationssaal gebracht.
Der Kater hat Epilepsie
und wird einer schwierigen
Hirnoperation unterzogen.
Ein Eingriff am Hirn
ist eine sehr invasive Sache.
Nur wenige Spezialist:innen
können eine solche Operation
durchführen.
* Piepsen
eines medizinischen Geräts *
Auch das Ohr verschwindet
im sterilen OP-Feld.
Nun bleibt nur noch
ein kleines Fleckchen Haut frei.
* Piepsen *
Mit dem Bohrer
macht Professor Forterre
ein kleines Loch in den Schädel.
Eine falsche Bewegung
kann verheerende Folgen haben.
* Bohrgeräusch, Piepsen *
Ein Restrisiko gibt es immer.
Komplikationen sind z.B. Hirnblu-
tungen wegen der vielen Blutgefässe.
Es kann trotz Vorsichtsmassnahmen
bluten.
Das Loch im Schädel wird
Millimeter um Millimeter vergrössert,
bis der Neurochirurg
die winzige Gewebsmasse findet,
die man auf dem MRI sieht.
* Piepsen *
Da ist etwas.
Es ist der Tumor.
Dieser muss nun ganz vorsichtig
entfernt werden,
ohne dass das Hirn beschädigt wird.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge, Piepsen *
Das hat also die Epilepsieanfälle
bei Arès ausgelöst.
Um herauszufinden,
ob der Tumor gut- oder bösartig ist,
wird das Gewebe ins Labor geschickt.
Merci. Merci.
Die ganze Operation
hat knapp eine Stunde gedauert.
Arès ist noch etwas verschlafen,
aber er hat es überlebt.
Nun muss er rund um die Uhr
überwacht werden,
weil das Risiko für Blutungen
immer noch sehr hoch ist.
Wenn alles gut ging,
sollte der Kater bald wieder
ein normales Leben führen können.
Von einer Katze erwartet man
weniger als von einem Menschen,
was die Körperfunktionen betrifft.
Ein Mensch sollte lesen,
zählen und logisch denken können,
weil seine Hirnleistung höher ist
als die einer Katze.
Eine Katze kann z.B.
ein normales Leben führen,
wenn sie die Toilette benutzen,
essen, spielen
und die Halter:innen erkennen kann.
Darum sieht man Folgeschäden
einer OP bei einer Katze weniger.
Arès kommt auf die Intensivstation
des Tierspitals.
Inzwischen ist es 19 Uhr geworden.
Die Operationssäle sind geschlossen
und das Personal geht nach Hause.
Alix ist wieder beim Kätzchen
mit dem gebrochenen Kiefer.
(Übers Telefon) Hallo?
- Ueli, hier ist Alix.
Ich bin in 3 Min. bei dir.
Der Venflon ist okay.
In welchen Saal soll ich kommen?
Äh ... In denselben wie gestern.
Ja, okay.
- Okay.
Danke.
Du brauchst keine Angst zu haben,
Kleines. Ja, ich weiss.
Alix bringt das verängstigte Kätzchen
zum Chirurgen Ueli,
der sich bereit erklärte,
zu operieren.
Kann ich helfen?
- Ich ... Ich suche Ueli.
Er war vorhin noch da.
Okay, dann sediere ich
diese Katze jetzt.
Sie wurde abgegeben.
Sie hat einen gebrochenen Kiefer.
Ueli hat angeboten,
sie zu operieren.
Ich mache die Sedierung
und dann warte ich.
Dann schauen wir.
- Okay.
Ganz ruhig, ganz ruhig.
Es tut mir so leid,
dass es am Freitagabend ist, Ueli.
Ein mehrfacher Bruch
in dieser kleinen Katzenschnauze.
Das zu operieren, ist nicht einfach.
Man muss den Kiefer stabilisieren
und so zusammennähen, dass es hält.
Zudem muss man ihn in der
richtigen Position stabilisieren,
damit es nicht aussieht
wie von van Gogh gezeichnet.
Wie ein kleiner Vampir.
- Genau.
Charmant.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Drehen.
Das Kätzchen liegt auf einem
provisorischen Operationstisch.
Dafür wird es
von den erfahrenen Händen
eines der besten Chirurgen operiert.
Schon fast wieder gesund.
- Es ist so süss.
Das heilt schnell, du wirst sehen.
Noch eine Naht und dann haben wir's.
- Super. Vielen Dank.
Die Hauptsache ist,
dass es gesund wird.
Vielen Dank. Ich hätte es
nicht einschläfern können.
So, hier noch ...
Super.
Vielen Dank.
Wir machen ein schönes Bild.
Tja,
schön ist es momentan nicht gerade.
Mit diesem Foto wird das Kätzchen
zur Adoption freigegeben.
Hallo, adoptiere mich bitte.
Das ist ein sehr junges Tier.
Die Narbe wird rasch verheilen.
In ein paar Tagen
oder in ein bis zwei Wochen
ist dieser Kiefer wieder ganz.
Hm, wirst du wach?
Kuckuck, Kätzchen. Kuckuck.
Gehen wir wieder runter?
Wir warten besser noch etwas.
Es ist ziemlich benebelt.
Oh.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Das Kätzchen liegt in seiner Box.
Und Alix kann endlich zu Abend essen.
Ja, ich arbeite zu viel,
aber das ist meine Passion.
Daher machte es mir weniger aus
als anderen ...
... zwischen 15 und 20 Std.
zu arbeiten,
am Wochenende
auf Abruf verfügbar zu sein
und nicht zu schlafen.
Ich weiss, dass ich das nicht
bis an mein Lebensende machen werde,
aber momentan ist mein Beruf
für mich das Wichtigste.
Ich habe noch Energie
für ein paar Monate oder Jahre.
Wir sind wieder in Farvagny/FR,
beim Cowboy Sébastien.
Morgens vor der Arbeit schaut er kurz
bei seinem Zebu vorbei.
Heute gab es eine Überraschung.
Ich hörte nachts schon ein wenig
Lärm, aber nichts Besonderes.
Als ich in den Stall kam, entdeckte
ich das kleine Zebu am Boden.
Es ist weiblich. So können wir
unseren Bestand vergrössern.
Florence muss trotzdem vorbeikommen,
um der Mutter zu helfen,
die Plazenta auszustossen,
ansonsten könnte Raja
eine Infektion bekommen.
Salut.
- Hallo.
Also ...
- Geht das?
Ein bisschen Wasser.
- Sie ist dort drüben.
Ja.
- Ich binde sie an den Baum.
Wir müssen sie anbinden.
Dann darfst du rein.
Ja, perfekt.
- So kann nichts passieren.
Raja hat
ein bisschen Probleme mit Menschen
und geht gern auf Fremde los.
Ja, man sieht, dass etwas raushängt.
Es ist schon ziemlich weit draussen.
Florence darf nicht ins Gehege,
solange Raja nicht angebunden ist.
Sébastien hat eine besondere Methode,
um sein Zebu zu bändigen.
Ich versuchte mal per Zufall, das
Zebu mit einem Lasso einzufangen,
aber es wollte
einfach nicht klappen.
Als ich aufgeben wollte,
ging ich nach dem Abendessen
mit einer Tüte Paprika-Chips vorbei.
(Lachend) Dann kam das Zebu
von ganz allein zu mir.
So merkte ich, dass das das neue
Zaubermittel ist, um es einzufangen.
Bisher klappt es gut.
* Kichern *
Ui-ui-ui. Hoppla.
* Sie lacht. *
Das Zebu ist hingefallen.
Ich war vorbereitet.
Ich weiss ja,
dass das Tier heftig reagieren kann.
Pass auf, wenn du von hinten kommst.
Sébastien warnt Florence
vor brüsken Bewegungen.
Also ... Die Handschuhe
ziehe ich schon mal an.
Das Junge hat sich versteckt.
Die angespannte Mutter
kann jeden Moment ausschlagen.
Die Hörner sind sehr gefährlich.
Sag es mir, wenn du bereit bist.
Ja ...
- Soll ich ihn halten?
Könntest du ...
- Ich komme.
Sei vorsichtig. Also ... Oh!
Wenn es schlecht reagiert,
springt ihr zur Seite.
Ich war schon sehr vorsichtig,
weil das Tier ausschlagen kann,
wenn ich mit der Hand
in es hineinfasse.
Sie hätte jederzeit mit den Hinter-
beinen nach mir treten können.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Oh! Uh-uh-uh.
Ich dachte, bei Wildtieren ginge das
automatisch, aber anscheinend nicht.
Hm ...
Hier drin ist nicht so viel Platz.
Zum Glück
ist das Kälbchen nicht so gross.
Hat das Kleine schon getrunken?
- Das ist die grosse Frage.
Heute Mittag versuchte ich es, aber
es suchte nur etwas nach der Zitze.
Als ich ihm die Zitze ins Maul
schob, trank es nicht wirklich.
Es kam mir seltsam vor, dass es
nicht bei der Mutter saugen wollte.
Es sah schwach aus, aber ich
verliess mich auf ihren Instinkt.
Vielleicht gebe ich ihm
doch besser die Flasche.
Willst du sie melken?
- Ja, das geht.
Wenn ich allein bin, geht das gut.
Tatsächlich?
- Ja.
Die letzten Reste der Plazenta
sind bald draussen.
Es ist bald vorbei.
Wenn das Zebu festgehalten wird,
ist es ganz ruhig.
Aber es gibt Momente, in denen
es genervt ist und ausrastet.
Dann müssen wir sehr schnell sein.
Florence rennt hinter einen Baum,
und Sébastien versucht,
Raja zu beruhigen.
Das habe ich nicht vorausgesehen.
Oh, scheisse!
Ich dachte nicht,
dass es sich so rasch löst.
Das Seil ist gerissen.
- Es hat niemand was gesehen.
Florence hatte Glück.
Es hätte schlimmer kommen können.
Ein Zebu ist halt keine Kuh.
Es ist viel schneller.
Es reagiert sofort und heftig.
Auch sein Fluchtinstinkt
ist ausgeprägter als bei einer Kuh,
trotz der gleichen Familie.
Während sich Raja langsam beruhigt,
untersucht Florence das Kälbchen.
Komm, zeig dich.
- Es ist ziemlich schwach.
Diesmal ist Florence
auf alles gefasst.
Achtung, sie kommt.
- Ja, ja.
Nicht, dass sie uns angreift.
Gabst du ihr mit der Flasche Milch?
- Nein, mit der Zitze ins Maul.
Und saugte sie?
- Sie sah es, saugte aber nicht.
Ich stellte im Magen
Flüssigkeit fest.
D.h., dass es getrunken hat.
Dass es so schwach ist,
kann damit zusammenhängen,
dass es ein Wildtier ist.
Diese verkriechen sich anfangs.
Wenn man es hochnimmt ...
- Komm.
Man muss es
auf die Beine stellen ...
... damit es aufwacht.
Komm, geh zu deiner Mama.
Hallo. So schwach
war es heute Morgen nicht.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Es ist richtig schlapp.
Ah, jetzt kommt sie.
Du musst ihm wohl die Flasche geben,
mit etwas Selen und Vitaminen.
Es liegt nicht nur daran,
dass es zu wenig trank.
Passiert mir nichts,
wenn ich vorbeigehe?
Wir gehen ja weg,
das ist weniger gefährlich.
Ich will nicht
auf den Hörnern landen.
Bringen wir das Kleine dorthin?
Sébastien muss das Kalb aus dem
Gehege nehmen, um es zu untersuchen.
Geht ihr vor mir raus?
Vor lauter Freude vergisst er,
dass man einem Zebu
nie den Rücken zuwenden darf.
* Drohendes Brüllen *
Oh-ho, oh-ho!
Ich wusste,
dass es aggressiv sein kann,
aber damit
hätte ich doch nicht gerechnet.
Er versucht es nochmals.
- Ich komme.
Raja will wieder auf ihn los.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ui!
* Drohendes Brüllen *
Ich gebe es euch raus.
Willst du wirklich,
dass wir es rausnehmen?
Sie macht dir alles kaputt.
- Ja, ja.
Ich glaube, ich helfe dir.
- Ich versuche es mal.
Florence gibt dem Kalb
rasch seine Vitaminspritze.
Okay, ich steche rein.
* Raja brüllt drohend. *
Ganz ruhig.
- Bleib cool, Raja.
Sie kommt gleich wieder.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Schau, es kann ja doch gehen -
sehr gut sogar.
Voilà. Soll ich ihm
die Flasche trotzdem geben?
Beobachte mal, wie es trinkt, ob es
heute Abend bei der Mutter geht.
Das Rodeo ist überstanden.
Sébastien ist glücklich.
Bei seinen Tieren fühlt sich
der Westernfan am wohlsten.
Ich könnte nicht ohne Tiere sein.
Muss ich ihr
keine Spritze mehr geben?- Nein.
Es ist eine Leidenschaft.
Von klein auf
hatte ich Tiere um mich.
Anders geht es nicht.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Ciao.- Tschüss.
Ciao.
- Gute Fahrt.
* Lockere Westernmusik *
Im Berner Tierspital
kümmert sich Alix liebevoll
um ihren Schützling Arès,
der eine schlimme Nacht
hinter sich hat.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Alles gut.
Die Hirnoperation ist gut verlaufen
und der entfernte Tumor
ist zum Glück gutartig.
Er war schon vorher etwas schwach.
Vielleicht hat ihm die Narkose
etwas zu sehr zugesetzt.
Okay?
Alix legt den Kater
in eine Sauerstoffbox.
Nun muss man
v.a. sein Verhalten observieren,
falls die Hirnoperation irgendwelche
Schäden hinterlassen haben sollte.
Er erholte sich gut,
auch seine Persönlichkeit
veränderte sich nicht stark.
Natürlich kann der Halter
das besser beurteilen,
aber uns gegenüber
verhielt er sich gleich.
In diesen fünf Tagen im Spital ...
* Schnurren *
... wurde Arès von Alix verhätschelt.
Besser könnte es ihm nicht gehen.
Oh, Schnurrli.
* Schnurren *
Ich höre dich zum ersten Mal
nach der OP schnurren.
Aber heute heisst es
Auf Wiedersehen sagen.
* Schnurren *
Gehst du nach Hause?
Ja, nach Hause.
Tierarzt wird man doch auch,
weil man Tiere liebt,
und nicht nur,
weil man die Medizin mag.
Daher ist das
sowie die Menschen, die verstehen,
was wir für ihre Tier tun,
sehr bestätigend.
Daher weiss ich, weshalb
ich diesen Beruf gewählt habe.
Arès, Arès.
Na?
* Schnurren *
Bist du zufrieden?
Ja, du schnurrst.
Ich glaube, er erkannte mich wieder,
als ich ihn streichelte.
Er schnurrte,
aber ich sah an seinen Augen,
dass er sehr müde ist,
Ruhe braucht und sich erholen muss.
Du bist müde, was?
Ich werde eine kleine Ecke
für ihn einrichten.
Normalerweise ist er auf dem Sofa,
aber nun muss er halt
auf dem Boden liegen.
Sie konnten mein Schätzchen
schon abholen?
Gehört er jetzt Ihnen?
- Er wird mir fehlen.
Ich hätte ihn fast hierbehalten.
Er ist total verschmust.
Er legt sich immer auf die Seite,
um am Bauch gestreichelt zu werden.
Auf ihn müssen sie gut aufpassen.
Nun muss ich jemand anderen
zum Schmusen finden.
Das wird nicht einfach werden.
Erleichtert nimmt Raphaël seinen
Kater mit nach Hause und hofft,
dass er nie mehr
einen Epilepsieanfall haben wird.
Du siehst gesund aus.
Dieses Kätzchen
rettete Alix vor dem Einschläfern.
Nur vier Tage sind
seit der Kieferoperation vergangen
und es geht ihm bereits bestens.
Na, du kleines Herzchen.
Gut, dass wir dich gerettet haben,
du Süsse, was?
* Schnurren *
Oh, du bist so eine Süsse.
Das Kätzchen war das Highlight.
Alle wollten es sich anschauen.
Streicheln durfte man es wegen
der Krankheitsgefahr noch nicht.
Er wurde rasch adoptiert.
Das Pflegepersonal hätte das Kätzchen
gern mit nach Hause genommen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Schau, da kommt die Mama.
Das Los fiel auf Stefania,
die das verletzte Kätzchen auf
der Notfallstation als Erste aufnahm.
Unter der Woche
lebt es hier bei mir in Bern,
am Wochenende
nehme ich es mit ins Tessin.
Es wird oft
durch die Schweiz fahren ...
... und mein Freund
hat bereits Katzen.
Es wird also
eine reisende Katze werden.
Ich bin sicher, dass er
viel Unsinn machen wird.- Ja.
Abgesehen
von ein paar verlorenen Milchzähnen
wird das Kätzchen
von der Operation nichts mehr spüren.
Alix freut sich
über dieses Happy End.
Auf der Notfallstation
gibt es ganz viele Fälle -
teils mit ganz schlimmen
Verletzungen oder Krankheiten.
Es gibt aber immer
diese eine kleine Geschichte,
die gut ausgeht und einen motiviert,
weiterzumachen.
So bleibt die Freude bestehen.
Einen schönen Abend.
- Tschüss, bis morgen.
Dank Alix, Ueli und Stefania hat das
Kätzchen ein schönes Leben vor sich.
Es heisst übrigens Orion.
* Kussgeräusch *
Na?
Drei Monate später
besuchen wir Arès und Raphaël
in Chézard-Saint-Martin.
Als er nach Hause kam,
wollte er aufs Sofa springen,
aber er schaffte es nicht.
Normalerweise
ist das einfach für ihn.
Als er oben war,
wollte er wieder runter.
Aber er fiel runter.
Arès.
Heute schafft er es
wieder überall rauf.
Ja, komm, hopp.
Voilà.
So.
Raphaël ist überglücklich,
dass sie in seiner Wohnung
wieder zu dritt sind.
Du schnurrst.
* Schnurren *
Ja, du bist zufrieden.
Es ist wieder genau wie früher:
Er will die ganze Zeit
gestreichelt und gehalten werden.
Wenn ich auf dem Sofa sitze,
legt er sich neben mich
und schmiegt sich an.
Arès ist wieder ganz zu Hause
und Epilepsieanfälle
hatte er auch keine mehr.
* Schnurren *
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Er ist so süss.
Nun fängt er an,
auf den Stuhl zu springen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021
Und mit dem Kiefer ist alles okay?
- Ja, alles gut.
Er hatte solches Glück, was?
- Total.
Er wird es dir noch schwer machen.
- Ja.
Viel Glück.
- Danke.